my name is michael case I worked with
Cara consulting we do a variety of
different things but basically solving
engineering problems for companies we
work with things as small as you know
little processors with no operating
system and 4k and really not much more
than that
up to large cloud distributed systems
that handle 30,000 requests a minute and
about Tim terabytes of data a day and so
everything in between is where we are
we're in medical equipment and
scientific equipment consumer products
some of its what we call honest work
honest work is what you can describe to
your mom and she knows that by the way
it's my mom to be very specific it's
something you could describe to my mom
and she would understand what the work
was and then we do other things probably
like most of us do every day too so this
this sessions labeled modern C++ in an
embedded world really what I wanted to
label it was contemporary C++ on bare
metal embedded but I was pretty certain
John would not accept that so we're back
with the the modern C++ unlike a lot of
sessions that you may have been where
where I'm speaking there will be very
little code in this there is there's
code at the end but the purpose of it is
not to explain a library or a technique
that we're using but a whole variety of
ways that we get to the point where we
could put embedded excuse me where we
can put C++ on small processors or in
this case just bare metal bare metal
meaning there's not an operating system
running there are a lot of reasons that
you might choose not to have an
operating system running on your device
and in this case this is what this
projects about so let's talk about the
project now anybody have a clue what
this thing is excellent well okay so you
will notice there are these these valves
or hoses this is a shaker and the
purpose of the shaker is to grab a tree
like an almond tree or something like
that and just you know rattle it without
hurting it
and have the nuts fall on to the ground
that it then sweeps in and pulls up and
goes the next one now you would think
that these things might run on some
diesel engine that's running around and
that's the true part but it's running
with the diesel engine that's just
pumping hydraulic fluid all these hoses
are all about because everything from
the drive system to steering and things
that spin in the shaker themselves the
whole entire unit runs off hydraulics
and this is very common in a lot of
industries so you have a big diesel
engine to do nothing more than to pump
hydraulic fluid through a manifold and
and to power other things in the system
now I don't know the last time it is
that you drove through the Central
Valley in California but if you do it's
fairly polluted and the reason is is
because of things like this for example
so California has grants in which they
give companies money to figure out how
to reduce that pollution we're doing
work for one such company and their
system hooks directly up to hydraulics
so typically this is not what you would
have you would not have these cute
little things at the bottom hook
directly up to like a hydraulic motor or
a cylinder you would actually have a
hydraulic pump going through a manifold
with valves that go on and off one goes
one way one goes the other way so you've
got these pair of valves so that you can
make things happen so it ends up
becoming a fairly complicated system the
idea is can you do this instead powering
it through electricity like a hybrid
system so you have a very small
gas-powered engine that powers like your
hybrid car and so instead all the
hydraulics are basically off of some
type of a an electric motor so that's
the idea in order to get to this
somewhere there is an embedded
something-or-another right because
everything seems to have an embedded
something or another the embedded
something or another here is an MTU you
probably put the term MCU the real big
difference is is that impe use have some
type of resource off board that they
need in order to do their job in this
case this mpu has memory ram absolutely
rom off board it has no flash it's
internal in it it has like everything
else in the world include
the kitchen sink but it doesn't actually
have a flash so that's off to the top
and you'll see that in this picture
we've got down to actually different
types of memory banks and an NFC which
is actually a memory bank too and they
communicate through different interfaces
depending upon what the unit is there's
a pressure sensor here there are two
different adcs analog to digital
converters one that communicates through
something called spy we'll talk about
more a little bit later another one
through I squared C and there's an FPGA
which we're also doing the the
programming for and we communicate to
that through a spy the NPU is speaking
to this encoder so if you have a motor
spinning you probably like to know where
it is for a variety of different reasons
and then we have some more interesting
things down here there's USB because
everybody wants to update things across
USB in the field
there's Kin Kin is the bus that's inside
your car that requires everything to be
able to communicate to each other so
there's a canned system EtherCAT is more
known inside of the industrial systems
it's like can running across an Ethernet
you can think of it that way so there
are some number of things that this mpu
needs to speak to handle and service in
a timely manner this is actually about
half of the i/o that it has to deal with
as far as peripherals that are connected
there are few other things this is a
science experiment this is what our
current lab bench are for this thing
looks like and this is a common way to
bring something up initially you buy
however many dev boards somebody will
sell you they sell you these dev boards
because they're trying to like for
example this one is an analog to digital
converter this one's another analog
digital converter
one's a spy ones and I squared C they
want you to buy the chips so they sell
you this dev board for very little money
and then you hobbled all these things
together now you'll notice this is all
hobbled together on top of like this
nice machined aluminum thing that's the
number one indicator that it was not a
double e that put this together it was
the mechanical engineer who said hey I
got this piece of aluminum so that's bad
but whatever but hands already yes sir
which one oh yes this you know what this
one is not hooked up to anything you
know why because sometimes you get a dev
board and it's configured to behave a
certain way and this one was to
configure we need to talk to it through
I squared see it's configured to speak
this other thing we can't make it speak
I squared C but it requires the movement
of 36 very small 0 own resistors on the
board and so weighing all of that we
decided that the board is sapote the
real board is supposed to be here next
week literally next week right but
they've been saying that literally next
week for I think we're on 40 days now or
something like that so there's been a
while as well as the rest of the bits
now when this is all put together the
board the fab you already have back
there you know they're fairly small so
all of this will shrink down to some
very small thing that goes inside of a
case all right so what's inside this is
just a a quick look of kind of what's
what is this MPU thing that we're
talking about and I don't want to get
into the gory details because of its a
small chart and and really what I want
to point out is this up here is the
processor that we're mostly looking at
it is a cortex r4 with an FPU so it's
been called an r4 f it has a variety of
different functionality and now notice
down here there's this thing they
magically called the RN engine and it is
an m3 at cortex m3 this actually has two
processors inside of it on the die as
well as a variety of different things
all kinds of things like tucán buses Wow
an ethernet mac built into it tons of
GPIO just lots of cred okay and then
another interesting thing is there's
this piece of memory over here and
another one over here this diagram is
like this is the brochure you look at to
see hey do I want to use this thing
because it's got all the right stuff on
it and you just call it quickly look at
these block diagrams right but this
tells you nothing about how they're
connected
so one thing that's interesting is if
you're going to try to figure out how to
get code to boot and load on something
without an operating system you need to
suddenly know a little bit about the
internals of it and when we go to look
at this what we find is that there is
the cortex right here and it has this
thing called a Vic whereas the m3 has
the NVIC this is one of the differences
between the r4 series is a real-time
processor which means that it has a
vector interrupt controller as opposed
to a nested vector interrupt controller
which is the m3 it also has this very
cool thing called TCM so TCM is tightly
coupled memory as opposed to you can see
the bus that is up here there's this
normal system bus you would expect in
memory somewhere right here so some
memory and so the m3 can go through
these buses and it can eventually get
here it's not a parent but the r4 can
also go to the buses and get to the
memory it needs to get to but the
tightly coupled memory is connected
directly to the core we get to it very
very quickly so that's great it also has
cache and things of that sort
the thing to think about at this point
is this system is sold as an r4 so
renesis sells this chip it's an r4 F and
it has this magical m3 in it along with
the disclaimer of don't touch that chip
we're going to do something with it
we're going to use it for our own
purposes that by the way is usually a
keyword for this is going to be a very
hard project to get my tools to work on
and we're gonna see some of that ok so
this the system actually has a bit of
hard real time associated with it also
you can imagine that as a motor is
spinning we're taking encoder
measurements along the way there's a
place where we have to take an encoder
measurement we have to do some
calculation we have to make an
adjustment to the output and do that
loop again right and did it pinned upon
a lot of things within the control
system the
concei of how often we have to do that
or how often to try to get how often we
have to do that for per rotation is
depend upon a variety of different
things ah what we're trying to solve in
the control system and then of course
the the motor doesn't spin at you know
one hurt
so it spins at a variety of different
speeds so let's say towards towards the
upper inch for hydraulics it's four
thousand Hertz so four thousand Hertz we
need to do so many samples per rotation
in order to get this done if we miss our
window that's bad
like people aren't dying bad but we
can't we have to hit the window so we
can make sure that the motor moves for
the next spot and does the proper thing
for with the right feedback so we have
this bit of hard real-time that also has
to occur okay so the question is why use
C++ for this project why not just use C
like everybody else in the right mind
uses C first I submitted a talk about
this so I have to use C++ because don't
really have another choice now actually
we I typically try to use C++ if I can
for a variety different reasons one it
provides abstractions that I believe are
easier to work with and have a I will
have a better result in the end I'm able
to think about problems at a higher
level now what's interesting is what I
think is a good thing the the majority
of the embedded world thinks is a
horrible thing
they hate abstractions we will see a lot
of that today I also think that there
will be fewer bugs and I'll finish
sooner if I can actually spend a couple
weeks or whatever it takes to get the
C++ compiler running and the reason for
that is if you spend any time at all
looking at embedded code you'll find
after no matter how many people or how
many companies you look at there are a
variety of different errors that occur
and they're like the same ones the same
types of mistakes that cause people
problems over and over again and those
problems are already solved with idioms
that exist in C++ so I don't want to
have those problems cuz to be honest I
would make them also likely and that
would be very embarrassing so I don't
wanna be embarrassed so we're gonna
start with getting some vendors
tools we want to get usually just the
vendor tools as is so we can get the
board just up and running have something
that we say hey this works it does
something that I understand and now I
can muck with it as opposed to just
starting from complete scratch so some
of the challenges or reasons that we'd
want to do this you'll see that there's
this thing right in the middle this code
generator for pin routing this is a this
is a common thing with with embedded
chips these days there's some type of a
fabric in there which is going to route
how things move around and sometimes
it's a proprietary format in order to
load that in and you have to use their
tools so you don't have a choice and
they're just built into these IDs that
you get which we'll talk a little more
about here soon
there's also code generator for in this
our case this are in engine that's the
m3 processor and then this working
startup code linker scripts and demo
code working is very subjective you
would never want to ship with what comes
you're going to you're going to spend a
lot of time vetting that and making sure
it does what you expect but it's gonna
boot and do something you're gonna make
a lot you know lines wiggle and things
of that sort I have no idea renesis
renesis something or another Ren
assesses the chip manufacture and the
idea of the RN engine I guess I should
mention this is so we have these two
processors the the r4 is for us to do
whatever we want and the m3 is basically
a coprocessor to handle communication
it's going to handle things like CANbus
communications it's going to handle the
encoder communication it's going to
handle EtherCAT the idea is we don't
want the real-time processor having to
deal with slow boring i/o activities we
want somehow to you have all the
protocols handled somewhere else and
then just get digested packets up all
right the story you're about to be told
a specific example of one groups
adventure however it represents the
engineers across the embedded
old that works better with a mic by the
way all right so here's our going we're
gonna start our toilet zone vendor saga
here and you know I just want personally
the vendor tool C++ compiler click the
link download it for Linux that's
personally what I want I just want you
to see what it says when I do this this
domain expired eight twenty three twenty
seventeen spinning renewal or delete
aren't you kidding me this is this is
not a fly-by-night chip manufacturer by
the way they make chips that go into
cars lots of them probably your car and
I can't download the tools by the way of
course just like you when you see this
message you're probably like I'm gonna
get that domain right now which by the
way I wasn't able to but I tried so it
ends up and I'm not the only person on
this project and so I did like anybody
my position should do at this point
which is delegate and so Sharon has 30
years of software experience and 15 and
embedded Sharon also likes to use
Windows you can in in our company you
can use whatever platform you want for
your machine and sheep it was the first
in a very long time to pick a Windows
machine when she started for us last
year I'm like awesome because I bet the
windows tools work so Sharon got tasked
with the first deliverable that we
needed to show as well as hey can you
also see if you get c++ working on this
device okay so yeah I did feel sorry for
Sharon I do we have donut dee I do bring
her a fritter especially because I do
feel sorry about that choice so this is
what you get
they called e to studio it's built on
top of eclipse like a lot of tools are
the thing to see is here at the top says
code generator tool tree I don't want a
code generator tool that's at the end of
the day this is going to cause me
problems ide czar how people like to
sell things they
love to do this how am I gonna integrate
this inside of my CI how am I going to
work was Sharon at the same time this
becomes a complete disaster these IDs
are horrible so we we start this thing
up yes okay the comment is that the IDS
concrete and I like abstractions alright
yeah yeah the concrete boots while I go
swimming so it ends up that version 14
it had some flaky behavior as tools
often do right I mean like not more than
normal flaky behavior for tools I was
just like II and so Sharon started
asking support a few questions the first
thing they said is use version 16 when
we actually had tried to use version 16
but the license file didn't work so we
had to go back to 14 because I worked on
that one and they got that worked out
and 16 you know okay so 16 in the second
comment of course not surprising was
goodness
don't you see plus plus like what's
wrong with these people so yeah that was
the comment from support don't use C++
oh yeah I get 16 oh and Sharon ended up
being quite clever and found a way to
get C++ to work it it required you know
one of those things where it was clearly
by accident right you load the file you
do this you change this project you back
out you go back you open this other
thing up and look now you it's in C++
mode awesome it wasn't supposed mode it
linked it loaded onto the device and it
kind of ran it was clear that the linker
script wasn't quite right there were
some problems right with the normal ones
like static initialization of
constructors and things like that it so
there are certain things that didn't
work but it wasn't a disaster it was
just a little flaky so I was like good
just don't use C++ okay whatever so okay
version 16 awesome if fix flaky flaky
behavior so that's good right that's the
good good the bad is probably the real
reason that support wanted us to move is
because we can
longer figure out our one cool trick in
order to make our C++ work anymore so
they basically figured out how to stop
that from occurring inside the IDE so
that ended that experiment and at this
point I was actually hoping that Charon
by this point would have written my
slides tiles probably taking notes and
telling me Sharon don't tell sharing
this later okay so it yeah at this point
it was apparent that Sharon needed to
continue working and see and making the
product do something and the C++ thing
was going to just be a lot more
complicated than we wanted for for the
moment and set it aside this is the ugly
part though and this is just a common
truth which is most of the embedded
world hates C++ they hate C++ for a
variety of different reasons
but the attitude that comes across and
you see it in tool vendors all the time
is we know best we know what's best for
you and as a result I'm going to disable
any ability for you to use C++ inside of
this IDE partially they don't want to
support it and I and I understand that
but it's almost like they go through
hoops in order to make it so incredibly
complicated and difficult that you just
give up and don't do it it's not just
that though almost always right before I
give a talk I go to the internet and the
internet never disappoints and Stephanie
had put up this this question I believe
just last week about whether people we
will use modern C++ when it's not just
readability and usability but they have
performance concerns and in general I
think as a community we currently have
some work to do because these are the
responses or just a couple of the
responses that have come back and these
people are not necessarily involved in
the embedded world
you can we all know what Arvid already
thinks because of being on slack write
that one down was easy I just saw his
picture and I cut and paste whatever
that was so you know there are a variety
of different opinions about C++ and none
of them are flattering so why is this
why isn't just the C++ sorry why is it
not just the embedded world but in
general a lot of people have this view
well a lot of people have this view is
because they think of C with classes
they think of what occurred in the 90s I
was introduced to C++ and started
writing C++ in 1990 and grew up with the
bush and rambha showing up at our office
during lunch Slayer and Miller giving
lectures trying to convince us that
there are certain object-oriented ways
to solve problems and the reality is is
they don't work really well right but if
you came up in that world and that is
your mentality of what you think C++ was
you left it a long time ago and you
haven't really rethought any of it at
all C++ is not obviously an
object-oriented language it can support
object-oriented constructs it can
support a lot of different ways for us
to write software we've got to pick the
right way at the right time so I think
that's part of it
the other is I've kind of alluded to
this a little bit is this idea of
abstractions in the embedded world
people don't like abstractions they like
to think that they write C code and what
they write is exactly what's in the
assembler and they believe that firmly
and I'll tell you why they believe that
firmly is they compile with - o0 a lot
because they want to see that it is very
disturbing when you hook your JTAG up
and you start like going through code
and it skips like where's my god what
happened to it right people don't like
that all right so let's back to this
like are our IDs all absolutely horrible
no no absolutely all horrible so you
know they serve a purpose
which I call time - hello world time -
hello world has driven a lot of Industry
embedded industry in particular for
probably the last 10 or 15 years dev
boards all these different things that
we get tools in order to make it so that
you can evaluate something very quickly
and pick that product part of me sales
but you know what it's not just the
embedded world how many of you have
written a header only library yeah
exactly
it's also in C++ because for some reason
time - hello world is really important
we're gonna get punished later for it
you get punished because of a header
only library if you don't want to learn
how to use your linker right because you
don't know your toolset in general
you're going to incur punishment every
time you compile as opposed to taking a
little bit of time and developing a
library that can be used for both I
totally understand it I also have header
only libraries right but time - hello
world drives a lot of things ok so there
are some good things it's easy to get
development boards up and running it
usually has a built-in way to upload
whatever you just wrote to the dev board
that's great because you don't have to
you know kind of mess around with that
debugging without hassle usually just
like built-in they're like what magic is
that that somehow on the chip it's all
working right you know it's just like it
just works the problems it's sent around
a single developer workflow usually hard
to integrate with a team typically
really hard to integrate with CI systems
it hides in my opinion too much of the
build magic I don't know what's going on
I don't know what's code generated I
don't know how to do that myself in such
a way that I can integrate that into my
CI
alright so making it all work so in
YouTube there's often in the comments
somewhere like at time and I tell you
but my clock is not working at time
such-and-such that's where you want to
go start watching so hopefully this is
maybe where you want to start watching I
don't know so how do we make it all work
together first I want to just use
standard tools I want to use GCC just
like plain old GCC
I want to use see make not really but
I'm going to try to use see make because
it's gonna be cool I hope and I want to
just see like static analysis and
analyzers continuous integration and
continuous deployment so in this sense
continuous deployment me means something
to different people to me it means that
the CI produces build results and
artifacts that can be used by the
continuous development that can be
pushed into a test frame into a test
section those can be promoted into
different types of testing phases and
release phases things of that sort so
and I want this so that I can actually
have traceability back from what ship to
actually word it all the code come from
so I think I'm gonna bag on it because I
have live in the embedded world a lot
this idea of rigor which you probably
live with most all the time doesn't
exist generally speaking in that world
which is why they also aren't interested
necessarily in something other than just
the IDE right there's not necessarily
that need so this was easy first step
I just went to arm comm and downloaded
it literally by pressing the download
button I mean how hard could that be
I also granted lucked out because the
cortex
for our excuse me r4 was just started to
get supported back in like October or
something like that so you know I was a
little lucky and then I just like hey
this works right a see make file that
seems like easy enough right now and
then of course you pause you go well
this is just not going to work there's
no way that this see make file possibly
could work for my target over there
because it's gonna build something for
my machine but that's okay because I
know already how to deal with that we
have dealed this all the time I just
need to give it a tool chain file right
so I need to tell what tool chain I want
to use in order to do this build so
let's set one up our C make system name
is going to be generic that basically
tells it that it's bare bare metal
we don't have an operating system and
we're gonna use an arm I give it a path
to where the compiler will be set up a
path and and what the cross compiler
will be and then a sign for each of the
these variables the see.they c++ the
linker and then this the thing we want
to look at just for a moment the object
copy so anybody familiar with object
copy there's a few okay so all object
copy is going to do basically is take
the output of the linker and allow us to
change the format into another format so
out of this is going to become elf I'm
gonna get elf format I don't really want
an elf file I don't know how to put that
on my flash write to be useful so I need
to convert that actually just into a raw
binary representation of what that
memory is that the elf describes object
copies going to allow me to do that and
then I'm going to say hey also when
you're trying to compile and check if
these compilers are valid or not use a
static library as opposed to trying to
build an exe because a static library
doesn't care about startup code and all
kinds of symbols and stuff it just wants
to compile some this is how you tell C
make use a static library instead if you
don't do this it's gonna complain
bitterly because they can't link when it
tries to say hey is that a battle
compiler it won't it won't pass so this
is kind of like the magic this is the
new magic and now you're supposed to do
it with the C mate all right that's what
it looks like for the first part we're
gonna add some more things which is like
hey you can find your executables on the
host but please do not find the
libraries from the hosts paths that
would be very disappointing and then
some other information like what kind of
MP you do we have
what kind of floating-point processors
inside of this there's actually a v3
processor D 16 which means that it is it
has 16 double wide registers for
floating-point inside of it so we give
it all of the details so that it will
generate code that is efficient for us
and then we actually cache that so we
tell C make stick this in the cache so
that everything else that tries to use
values can find it because I'm not gonna
look inside of the variables alright so
there you go that was the C make magic
I'm not a C make expert that's what I
did to make it work that's the stuff I
also learned this conference that I can
stick it all in one slide I just say see
if you make it smaller it's it's on one
slide oh the compiler options are easy
because so figuring out the compiler
options is not difficult in the sense
that these options I just need to look
up and see what kind of core am I you're
dealing with so these are just just
mapped to the core that I have and the
options that that core has related to it
so it's not difficult to find the
options well it might be difficult is if
you're trying to compile something that
works for lots of different things I
don't care about that yeah richer
suggesting you can look at the IDE
output and see what it what it's using
for spew that that works to a level like
the get things up and running level it
probably may or may not work for
optimizing making sure you have the
right thing in fact it would have worked
for this because the IDE actually wanted
a soft floating-point unit yeah there's
plenty of forums that might give us
information so looks like zombies in the
front row that I'm criticizing maybe
their IDE and didn't realize it awesome
and they don't use it internally Oh
scratch that part all right so all right
former employer so now we're just gonna
go ahead and run that and type me
alright and and then I get this as an
output hey you're missing this symbol
called exit alright I I make I'm making
some progress right but the exit symbol
underscore exit something needs to
define that it doesn't just happen and
when you start doing embedded especially
on bare metal you start realizing how
amazingly wonderful your tool vendors
are and all the startup code they supply
to you and the linker scripts that are
like just tuned just right for your
operating system and you're like those
are the best people in the whole world
like you guys are excited about about
whatever the next seventeen feature is
I'm just excited that I can just type in
make and not have to do what we're about
ready to do alright so you get to this
point and you realize okay well that
that's fine now I've got to do some work
the work is is you've got a you've got
to actually crack open the manual and
figure out what happens with this device
when you hit the reset line every device
is different they all behave differently
they do different things when I can say
crack open the manual this portion of
the manual for this device is 2600 pages
it's actually just over 2,600 pages it
it it just like any good ISO standard it
says please see document such-and-such
for how the arm instruction set set set
works right it doesn't even talk about
arm it doesn't talk about any in that
stuff it just talks about like registers
and things like that so you go and you
find a section this talks about what
happens with reset you learn about
memory layouts what are the needs for
startup what kind of peripherals what
are they going to need do they need
power up at certain time what ordering
does that occur and of course we're
going to actually need to enable a
couple more languages right in order to
do all this so this is what the memory
map looks like the basic version of the
memory map out of the manual you can see
on the far left hand side is the cortex
m3 the thing that we're not
post a touch but we're going to have to
know how to get the code loaded into it
at some point for this to work so we got
to know a little bit about it
the r4 is right next to that the the see
if I can get this to work here
maybe not okay you can see that our r4
starting at address zero is this tightly
coupled memory there's an a and there's
a B the a is 512 K the B is 32 K it
works out the the 512 K tightly coupled
memories we're gonna stick our program 0
is not null people it's a real address
that's important and be tightly coupled
memory is actually we're gonna put our
stack we're gonna throw our stack into
the B section so once we start
understanding where things are we're
going to go inside and create a linker
script the linker script is going to
start saying this is where the memory
laid out is this is where addresses
exist these are real addresses as far as
that processor is concerned when it
accesses address 0 this this one in
particular the chip selects work in such
a way that it's accessing tightly
coupled memory a so we set this up and
then you know the left rest is left to
the student we won't bore you to death
but this is kind of what a linker script
looks like and part of the reason for
throwing this up here knowing that this
is probably a diverse crowd is some of
this is gonna actually look really
familiar to you you you may not know
what the startup what start looks like
but you know there's an interrupt vector
that's going to end up here at the
beginning for us there are some other
things in here like your text you've
heard of text right shake your head yes
you've heard of text read-only data
there's gonna be a read-only data
section oh the tours you this linker
script set up for C++ we're gonna have
our constructors and our D structures
listed here these are static things
we've got some more RAM we've got where
is it
oh there it is the BSS section towards
the end there's this goes on for many
many pages alright and the linker knows
we're into memory to put something
because of a linker script now in this
case we're not
locating anything we have to stick it
exactly where it belongs so that it
works that's what the chip expects and I
think it's relocated now we come back
and we say okay let's update our C make
file a little bit more and add some more
stuff
now that tool file that I had you some
of this stuff would go in here for
example starting from the top project
you now can see that we've actually
we're not going back up just 30 seconds
but you like it just started talking can
we do that
so here the top the project file we're
gonna add a couple more languages so
we've got now c++ c and assembly we're
going to set up a linker script and a
bunch of flags that we want to use
notice we're going to compile with OS
that size size is very important to us
size is basically saying oh - except for
the optimizations in which size would be
impacted
so it's Oh to optimizations except for
the ones where size would be impacted
we're also turning on linker time
optimizations so LTO has to be turned on
in two spots you turn it on at the
compile because it puts additional
information inside of the elf file and
then you turn it on at the linker and
the linker uses that information part of
the ast information to make things even
smaller for us so we're gonna get
optimization both of those we're gonna
tell it no start files we don't want
start files and we don't want exceptions
for lots of reasons
so we've we get done with all of this we
add our linker script which somewhere on
here there we are oh that was sad so the
linker script right here we we just add
that in as part of our link flags and
now we're gonna go ahead and add in the
other things we need like we're gonna
write some assembly for startup we're
going to have some assembly of our
vector table we're going to have some
assembly about the loader in it and then
we're like I'm done writing assembly and
then I'm gonna write the rest of the
loader in C which will eventually call
main okay so there's all the stuff that
runs before main gets the chip working
the way it's supposed to sets up
interrupts properly things of that sort
and then we're going to add a custom
command this is that custom command
using this object copy those
mentioning before where we're going to
take whatever was just built this is
that elf format and we're going to
actually output that in a binary format
hmm we run it again and ooh bummer fail
now remember I went through great
extents putting in this flag to tell it
to not actually try to compile an exe to
make sure that the compiler worked and
it it seemed like it was working when I
just had the C++ compiler so I said no
that was just try it with just the C
compile it works with just the C
compiler in fact it works if you have
one compiler listed but if you have two
compilers listed whatever the second one
is seems to ignore the flag and at this
point is about ready to give up on C me
cuz it was just for bonus points and I
felt like I was really losing so yeah
I'm packed it even I downloaded built
the latest dev version maybe that would
do it finally I'm like okay well just
one more try let's look inside the magic
file the magic file and look at that
there's a way to actually say hey the C
compiler works don't even try to test it
okay
now that's not inside of the
documentation they've rewritten their
documentation I can't wear a couple
times now on on how cross compiling
works so as far as I could tell both of
the things that they tell you for advice
you know night and either the things
that they tell you for advice work but
but this works so now we just add this
to our command line we compile ooh
things are great and you'll notice what
came out is of this file if I say file
the output this is that elf thing right
and we took that and we ran object copy
on it we made this thing called kernel
bin and it's just a data file this is
just a mapping that I can actually flash
on to the device so where's this going
to go well the other little thing that
we haven't talked about is but you know
nothing actually just boots that would
be nice but that's just not how things
work especially if it has a tightly
coupled memory what it does is it goes
and it says where's a bootloader that I
can load into what you're going to use
later for some other memory stack and
I'm gonna run that out of stack so that
you can actually load from whatever you
need to and set up the program and make
it all pretty and then start it so the
reality is we have to still write a
bootloader
so we're gonna her head a bootloader but
we're not gonna do that today so let's
move on any idea how much time I have
yeah I don't either I'm at 45 I have 45
left thanks all right so now this is the
other place where there might be a
youtube comment that says the good stuff
starts at time mark 45 so let's talk a
little bit more about why C++ so zero
cost abstractions are things that were
used to on a common basis if you're here
at this conference you're used to this
concept and and I'll tell you now I'm
half pandering to the YouTube audience
at the moment because not everybody
knows what that is
so we're gonna actually talk a little
bit about zero cost abstractions another
reason that I like to use C++ is because
the abstractions are going to help me
debug my business logic on a nice
computer sitting somewhere in a nice
location that doesn't have a JTAG cable
hooked up to it okay and I want to be
able to do things like enforce
correctness through types and again I
want this I want an abstraction so if
you were at Ben's talk earlier today
this is a lot what bin was talking about
also we want to take the what's and move
them up and we want to take the house
and push them down the things at the top
are the value that you add every day you
may not think about your job that way
you might think about your job currently
as implementing the very best state
machine in the whole world but actually
it's what the state machine does that
gives the company value
it gives the product value and we want
to actually spend a lot of time thinking
about those things and moving it up and
the things that are Hardware specific
the things like drudgery we want to move
down into into libraries okay we want to
we want to push that down now this might
seem obvious to you but this is really
uncommon in an embedded project
everything is twisted together the
value-added proposition the what it does
is tied up with the how to do it always
they're just tangled together there is
no separating them which is why the idea
of just running this on your own machine
in a mode which doesn't require a real
simulator is foreign because if you
start doing this right if you push the
value up in the hardware spec down you
now you have this nice dividing line
where you can think about what is it
that this thing solves and how can I
actually make sure it's going to do that
with tests alright so if you haven't
seen it watch Ben Dean's oh that's
almost embarrassing well anyhow from now
on being and his talk was easy to use
hard to misuse declarative style and C++
alright so yeah we'll get that later
what's a zero cost abstraction so let's
just talk quickly about this if I have a
program main and I can type some numbers
in it and I want to go ahead and count
the number of eight that are in there I
can call this method called count value
and I pass it the pointer at the
beginning and the pointer at the end and
and I want eight alright and how do we
might implement that you know there are
a lot of different ways this would look
very familiar to somebody both in C and
C++ you can
to figure out what this thing's going to
do right we could just iterate through
and try to figure out if the thing
that's there is an eight and if it's an
eight
then I increment my sum and at the end I
just return it makes sense all right
so this is the output for that and it
might be a little surprising just that
it's so much when we start looking a
little more carefully what we see is up
here we've got our method count value
and it's still inside of our assembly
and we have here your inside is our main
here's our call oh we see the call to
string too long it's over here because I
got in lined right so we have an inline
version we're not calling count value
and we've got count value so one thing
that we can look at right away as we say
oh well if I stick this inside of an
anonymous namespace then the system
would know that it's not being used by
any other translation unit right and I
would expect then that would do
something for me at least and it does
this is what I get out okay so this is
the setup now the question is and and
probably everybody in here I hope does
this cut bother you
yeah this code this code bothers us it
feels uncomfortable it makes us or it
should makes us make us feel a little
uncomfortable for a lot of reasons and
we could just start with the raw loop
right and we can look at it and go you
know we have actually a perfectly good
algorithm that's supposed to do this for
me count if I could I just use count if
maybe I could just use count if that
might be nice so count if takes
iterators and a predicate so I'm going
to just pass in the predicate by the
lambda now if you are used to algorithms
this is easy to read if you're not used
to algorithms
this is incredibly foreign but
everything that we start with is foreign
at some point right and this becomes
easy to identify and read at some point
because we just read it count if count
if so what does this do though well it's
almost identical the raw loop and the
algorithm are almost identical now I
don't think I don't think people in this
room were probably surprised by that you
probably expected that to occur if
you've watched any of Jason's talks
right his weeklies you know that this is
going to happen but this is a foreign
concept to most people in the embedded
world because the for loop I understand
I'm going to step through that in fact
that's how I'm going to discover that
most of the world works I'm going to use
my debugger and step through things and
watch we want to lift ourselves up out
of that right and get to this
abstraction where we just say things
like that and realize that there's
actually no penalty zero cost
abstraction we have an abstraction it
didn't cost me anything to use it it was
correct by single stepping through it in
the debugger and once they convince
correct
okay so Marshall without actually
disclosing when he went to college
remembers reading a book that on real
paper that basically said you would
write software compile it and step
through it to prove to yourself that it
did what you expected it to do now
you're not a plant this is awesome
because most of the embedded world still
works this way
they still step through everything to
make sure that it does what they kind of
expected you to do this is also now
where I'm gonna get a lot of comments in
YouTube about how wrong I am but Tom Tom
Tom alright so here's one question is
what if I you know what if I got totally
fancy and I used captures because the
cap should be a little more closely
aligned to the other code that I had you
know what what is the impact of doing
something like that are things gonna go
wild well know things look the same in
fact it's identical still it's the same
so the zero we would expect it to be the
same the zero caught the concept of
zeros cost abstractions is that we can
think at a higher level and not pay the
price that's the other half of the
problem so while I can't also debug
through these things I also worry about
how much code is is generating what is
it creating okay so what if I did this
with what the data set what's going to
happen well you know now I've got the
data set and here it is it's gonna be
part of that BSS that gets loaded in we
saw a little earlier you know that that
might make me sad because you know I'm
looking at this I'm like it should just
know all right so what's the answer yeah
okay so we just like make this thing
Const so now we've got Const up here and
the compiler should know that this
thing's not going to change on me and
sure enough it doesn't I now have a main
that loads two in return and what's
going to be the return the question is
why did I not use stood begin and stood
in that would be one more thing to
discuss and explain to somebody who's
coming from a sea world so it's just to
make the slide a little friendlier yes
I'm I'm really trying to conserve a
tonzura cost abstraction at the moment
doesn't cost anything to do this
and the compilers gonna do what you want
now let me tell you at this point if you
were I've talked about this with this
particular slide at a chip manufacturer
and they kind of freaked out at this
point they were not happy because the
compilers doing a lot of stuff for you
that makes us excited it makes a lot of
people very nervous all right
yes so this is the deal suddenly they
can't reason about what it's going to do
but literally people think they write C
code the assembly looks just like the C
there's nothing going to happen in
between right we know that's not true
also and it's even more so not true in
this case but yes I'm gonna remember
that yeah so richard has no sympathy for
trip manufacturers who reorder his
instructions okay so polymorphism is
another thing that that people worry
about we're not going to we're not going
to go through this example the CRT P
because we're gonna run out of time if
we do but at the end of the day we want
polymorphism how many of you know what
CRT PU I don't know you asked the wrong
way I mean don't know what CRT PS okay
so we're for those who don't know what
we're going to try to do is we're gonna
create polymorphism but most of that we
don't want runtime polymorphism we need
the concept of polymorphism and we
already know at compile time what it is
and so we see RTP gives us a technique
to do that now it ends up that if we go
through that that process if we if we
write something with with normal runtime
polymorphism we will automatically get
all kinds of crud like virtual tables
and runtime types and we don't make a
call we actually have to load where the
the vector table is then to figure out
an office
and then make a call we've got a lot of
additional overhead right if if most
embedded people would just die at this
point they just this is this is
unacceptable so we normally don't need
runtime polymorphism but that's actually
not what we need most the time we like
polymorphism so there's a way of doing
it in static CRT P so I'll let you look
up the rest of that of how that works
this is the this is the key though is if
you don't if you use CRT P to do your
polymorphism you end up with something a
bit smaller like quite a bit smaller now
I had to actually make that other slide
trick it by turning D virtualization off
so the compiler can be smart and can see
through these things and D virtualize
normal what we don't think of normal
runtime polymorphism but it can't always
do that it's like a barrier that it has
to now work at to see through so you can
get you can you can get this with D
virtualization which is nice
some take away those are just from this
part at this point when we have inline
functions when we have the compiler
helping us out the code that's generated
doesn't look like the code that we wrote
and that's going to be potentially
troublesome if we're debugging use Const
when you when you can make all kinds of
things that are cost Const and stepping
through things is going to be difficult
when you're debugging let me give you an
example our countif that we had
previously so this is the countif first
of all if I look at this is like what is
this what is this garbage you know that
part makes sense to me
I got that but what is this garbage
right so this is gonna be just a little
frightening as I'm stepping into this
first let's just don't step into
standard algorithms but as we just heard
from Marshall this is how people do
things so let's say we didn't turn
optimizations on let's turn no
optimizations on all right here is what
we're gonna have for our output and that
page
and that page and that page and that
page do you remember what this was
before can you see why people like get
frightened because they're like
compiling with a zero so don't do that
OS OS all right it this is not a repple
system it's not read evaluate print loop
write reason about your code write your
code in such a way that you use high
level abstractions without having to do
this this is actually why by the way
people use zeros they look it up and
they say reduce compilation time and
make debugging produce the expected
results this is the default all right
all right this is somewhat of a very
personal opinion but I think if you open
your debugger you already have problems
and I don't mean you already have
problems like you have a bug I mean you
have something that you were unable to
reason about which is why you're opening
your debugger or you've grown into the
habit of using your debugger to figure
out what your code does spend time
understanding what it is that you wrote
and look at the code you should be able
to noodle about it and reason about it
and say most likely this bug is in this
location for most of the time granted
there are some hard time hard bugs
sometimes but generally speaking you
should be able to really think about
your code and know where the problem
probably is Richard opens up the
debugger to understand other people's
code I think that's also a problem
Richard but yeah
so other people do that so I I think one
thing and and this is kind of regardless
of whether in the embedded world
is like we rely on the dub bugger a lot
for something other than debugging we
rely on it as a way to try to figure out
when the world's going on as opposed to
actually understanding the code that we
supposedly wrote or the code that were
supposedly maintaining and if we
actually understood that code we
probably wouldn't have to open up our
debugger so often we could probably
actually pinpoint the idea or the
problem pretty quickly without doing
that so here's the other part yes this
is gonna be horrible on target you're
not going to get the debug version on
the target it's not gonna fit with the
debug symbols and that's okay because
we're going to go back to this thing
where we're trying to put the value
proposition higher up our business logic
is going to be high up we can test to
make sure that actually the algorithm
does the proper thing on a machine and
know with confidence at least that on
this particular machine it worked that
doesn t is gonna it's not gonna work on
the target right it might not work on
the target but at least you have
confidence that the logic is correct
you can write tests and know that it's
correct yeah so the kind is done I tried
the og options and some using GCC that's
actually - OS - og is the way to go
and yeah that's there are plenty of
articles about that combination works
really well you yeah those two are
combined ok part of the reason I'm doing
this is in the hardware the hardware
specific things right are on the
hardware and then I can stub them out
using techniques that have zero cost
abstractions there's there's no cost for
that abstraction that I'm going through
and I can worry about hardware specific
things bring the board up bright the
drivers the hardware stuff and make sure
that that works while somebody is
writing and making sure that the logic
is working properly for whatever you're
solving that the algorithms do the right
thing that you know this crazy control
loop that we're writing that the math is
proper for that and does what it's
supposed to do
the type system helps us enforce
correctness and so we want to use that
as much as possible we want to move as
much as we possibly can to compile time
errors we want to error out with the
compiler saying the thing you just tried
to do it completely invalid don't do
that we're gonna see some more of that
all right thick we're gonna look a
couple of abstractions with a little bit
time we got remaining here so one of the
things that the MP who has to talk to is
this FPGA and the way it's going to do
that is through some of this called spy
so spy is used from everything from like
your SD cards that's how spy works or
how your SD card works it's on honest
five of us and it has this idea of one
side is considered the master one side
is the slave we've got a clock and you
have mo si which is master out slave in
on the other side you have master in
slave out and it's just this chain that
goes around and the master side is going
to do the clocking and it's just a
serial thing that can be fast and you
can start paralyzing the serials in
order to do some other neat tricks but
there is no way for the FPGA to say hey
I want to talk to you in PU unless
there's some other line going back the
IMP you is going to make all that
decision going forward it's pretty
common whether we're talking to the FPGA
are we talking to the IDC's or the
pressure sensors there's a lot of
different things we have to talk to you
that are on different spy buses and they
have a protocol just like anything else
would have a protocol right that you
have to talk to so how can we implement
this this is not the project that I'm
currently describing this is a project
from last year that somebody had some C
code that we were just replacing on and
this is how the very exact same problem
was solved getting ready to write out to
the spy you get something that's going
to describe what you're talking to and
now notice we have this int thing and a
value they've got a call back and who
knows what this context void star thing
is I'm gonna set up a length data 0 is
the VAT you know the command value
that's going to go across I'm gonna
copy this value bit in and I'm going to
call request and request basically bit
bangs us out some port it's just a
function pointer a bunch of other things
that you don't see eventually it's going
to be an interrupt of things that come
back something's going to get queued up
there's some main loop in essence you
can think of it that way that comes back
pulls things off queues and processes
them for this particular one yeah at
some point it'll get anyone we get
called on the interrupt the interrupts
will say hey main loop when you're
available that type of thing so I want
you to take a look what what stands out
maybe in fact in this one in particular
what's like the what's an obvious error
that's going to be able to be made here
Matt actually talked about in his
lightning talk the interface just like
what I'm so but yeah yeah yeah mix-up
thing and mode and you know this is a
common problem it's a really common
problem especially if you have
interfaces that look like this and so
how would we naturally fix this yeah
make them different types we just use
strong types right and then the compiler
would tell me right away that I made a
mistake which could be a good thing this
is actually this project was also
controlling motors and getting those two
things mixed up would have actually been
a very bad idea
so using strong types helps helps us do
the right thing at the time that we're
actually making our calls alright so
this is what that looked like
now I replaced that code set with um
brought in C++ and there was a bunch of
communication problems going on and the
first thing is like I mean it looks like
we have a protocol let's just use types
to represent the message type and then
this
stuff that's inside of the struct will
be the payload that's gonna go across
that seems to make sense to me and then
I could just write a serializer for that
and I could talk directly to hardware by
somehow sending these things out so
create a protocol now I actually it's
not just a thing that I had I actually
there was a left or right or another
thing right and it would've been nice to
call him by that as opposed to some
integral values what was there before
and I set up the struts
we have this magic that occurs on the
other side if you're familiar with
fusion the magic that's over here is
very similar it adapts this thing so
that I can make a tuple of references to
the struck then I can play with it in
meta programming all I want later on and
then I'm going to describe the protocol
with this message list these are the
things that can be sent out that port
these are recognizable things by putting
this stuff in I'm building into the type
system that I can use later some got in
some caches if I make mistakes if I send
the wrong type out the wrong port like
you know I'm asking the FPGA to do
something that the ADC knows how to do
right things like that so by using the
type system to tell what can go in and
out of places then I'm gonna find those
problems like real early because it
won't compile and somehow I'm gonna get
one of those then set thing mode types
and I'm just gonna call send message and
then the magic will happen now we're not
going to talk about what the magic is
underneath I've given plenty of talks
that talking about serialization using
declarative type things and the just go
look at one of those talks it's it's
very similar to that the advantages is
for all the types that I can possibly
think of I don't have to add new icky
code I don't have to go and write this
stuff for the next thing I have to do
all I have to do is add a new struct
with the data types I need adapt it so
it knows actually in the metaprogramming
drug junk what to do and I'm done
junk yes so the mental burden is gone
and I know about correctness now I can I
can deal with what am i sending as
opposed to all the mechanisms of how to
send it
so this ended up taking it from 3,000
children I need two lines of code down
to eleven ninety four lines of code by
using this declarative syntax instead
now as Ben said earlier it's not about
reducing lines of code but like I like
to say every line of code is a liability
so I'm happy to do that but it also lets
me just think at a higher level bytes of
code so the question is is how many
bytes of code to this generated I don't
have that number but it's small yeah it
probably about a third of what I had
before yeah it's quite the bytes of code
it's quite a bit smaller than before
yeah so how I think about code is if it
fits on the 512 I mean how many of you
had a Commodore 64 right this is
significantly larger if it fits on that
I'm happy no no tricks like that so
they're questions like how does the
serialization code work I will show you
afterwards it's like alright so I want
to about now another abstraction and
this one this one's a dear to my heart
because it happens all the time in
embedded systems and and it should
probably happen a whole lot in non
embedded systems which are state
machines we kind of live and breathe on
state machines we don't sometimes
identify them as state machines but we
have state machines everywhere and state
machines are really wonderful things we
should just like use them we don't use
them I think as often as we should is
because they're a pain to implement so
here is a state machine this is using
UML syntax
we've got when a connect message occurs
or event call the establish function or
it's going to perform the establish
function as it moves into connecting
this one right here ping it's a self
transition
ping is the event is valid is the guard
condition and then reset timeout is then
going to be the function that's
performed so you know most of us have
seen code that you switch statements and
if blocks to implement things like that
and they become completely
unmaintainable at some point it's like
the person who wrote it knows how it
works no one else knows how it works but
if you could somehow lift yourself out
of that abstraction and just believe
that state machine generators can do
what they're supposed to do then you
could think at a higher level the bin
was talking about like operator
overloads and people frowning on them I
think we're in one great reason for an
upper operator overload is for a
domain-specific embedded language like
this one so this is Chris juicy axe
boost SML and notice that the the the
syntax looks a lot like the UML syntax
it's not like having to learn something
completely foreign but these this
transition table represents the state
machine I can easily go back and forth
between the two of them I can look at a
table and realize that oh I'm going to
move from the connected state if there's
a ping is valid as the guard it's going
to do this reset timeout oh it has no
destination which means that it's itself
the one below it is whether there's a
timeout event it's going to actually
runs established and it's going to move
to the connecting state this is a really
nice way to write a state machine right
I've lifted myself out of the drudgery
of switch statements and if and the how
to do it and now I'm worried about like
what are we trying to accomplish I can
look at this and verify that the table
does why I expect it to do this is like
the business logic I'm trying to solve
the motor is going to do what I wanted
to do that type of thing right and this
is where I want to live so what does
this look
like we saw the state machine part what
is this established well-established
it's a callable thing a no Larry
callable thing and what is is valid well
it's it's just something that will be
called with the event and it will return
a boolean so this is a really nice
abstraction allows me to think higher
it's declarative in nature right
declaring when I go to actually now use
the state machine we'll have a state
machine object and I call processed
event and I pass in a type right all of
our events were types well how
convenient is that because I just got
done writing a serialization thing that
deals with types I'm starting to lift
myself into this position where all the
tools that I'm using now are are going
to check themselves at compile time to
make sure that I'm forming and
constructing something that's valid this
is out of chryses by the way all of
those items were out of Chris's slides
and you can look up Chris and see here's
the github for it look him up online and
see different talks that he has as he
goes through this and gives the details
you know one of the things that comes up
quite a bit is well yeah how big is the
state machine though what does it
require for State well if you were to
write this with an enum or a switch you
would take up a byte to represent that
machine well SML also takes up one byte
to represent the machine if you're naive
ly to write this with a you know a
series of classes you're gonna end up
with three bytes so it ends up that it's
just as efficient and watch his
presentations it is it is very very
impressive all right so let's see if we
can lift ourselves even higher up out of
this I personally think the downside of
state machines hierarchical state
machines is that they could come very
complex very quickly I only like to
think about one thing at a time
when I'm dealing with embedded systems
and I want to deal with that one thing
in the state machine for that and verify
it and I would really like to have
distributed state machines state
machines that communicate to each other
in passive ents that's what I would like
well ends up back in the 90s it was this
thing called real-time object-oriented
modeling it was the predecessor to UML's
real-time extensions and real-time
Audrey - modeling had this concept of
distributed state machines in which you
would describe not just the behavior as
a state machine but you would describe
than what they called structure included
ports and ports or how state machines
sent information back and forth to one
another and it allowed you then to bind
machines together you could either do
this binding at runtime or you could do
it at for our sake we can do it at
compile time so if we can do a compile
time binding as you could imagine from
Vittorio's talk yesterday that gets rid
of all of the overhead I already know
what I need to call into so we have a a
library called Loddon that does this it
allows us to take one more step back
looking at this this bit right here like
what are these communications well what
they are is this abstraction we're going
to set up a protocol that port
represents a protocol so I'm gonna have
again some types that represent the
messages I can send the type is the
message type the data inside of the type
is the payload that can be sent and then
I'm gonna actually describe a protocol
protocols have valid input messages and
valid output messages things that they
can send in and out of a port and then
once I described that in Laden we use
SML to describe the state machine it
used to be MSM but SML compiled smaller
and it's faster so we use that to
describe our state machines and then we
use a syntax that looks like this crease
some ports of what the tags are going to
be called I have an app port a step
report a time report and then I just I
create a type list these
the ports these are the ports and these
are the protocols that they're
representing now when I go to bind these
together these distributed state
machines it can check at compile time
that I'm connecting to things that are
actually allowed to actually send
messages back and forth that's nice and
it gets rid of the overhead that's
associated with it it allows me to think
at a higher level again the one other
thing and Bryce kind of actually
mentioned this he was like well where's
that callback going to run by doing this
we have what we call the controller it's
handling all of the messaging that's
going back and forth between these state
machines and in our distributed model
it's also our multi tasking model so to
speak the controller can actually
implement and impose policies of any
sort that we would like it can take care
of the fact that there are interrupts
occurring in the system that it should
not cause trouble with and what to do
with those and how to get them back into
the system and where to where to move
things so it gives us again a nice
abstraction for that the other thing is
if you notice we were simply binding
protocols which are types and now I can
bind a protocol that represents that SPI
bus I want to talk to or the FPGA or the
whatever I want I just say bind to that
Hardware device because I'm already
sending types all over the place they're
already serialized when they get there
and and communicate properly so this is
an another way of just thinking at a
higher level a couple more things to
think about or to look at the this
conference Odin gave a talk on mix-ins
it's a it's a great talk talking about
he has this agent thing that he's been
working on for a while and a series of
libraries the concepts in it are really
great for the embedded type work where
you're trying to take a lot of different
information and figure out how to
assemble something that makes sense for
the different the different platforms
watch those yeah I also have something
about these special registers that ships
have so every device when you when you
look at a device it's just memory you're
accessing what appears to be memory
memories hooked up to some bits that do
something or another this particular one
is this module stop control register and
you'll see when you look every single
bit in here controls stop controls of
something different some other module
it's not like you know this memory
address controls this one thing it like
it controls a whole bunch of different
things and he has a technique of dealing
with that also which is actually very
clever all right some final thoughts
will be using C++ on the project it was
hard to tell I could see tails back
there typing to sharing right now we are
using CMOS flows continue so these
things aren't now aren't news tool
vendors aren't super friendly to C++ but
my experience has been it's worth the
effort to figure out how to make it make
it go and unlike most of the Stack
Overflow community for other questions
you might have the community is very
small that's trying to do this and so it
takes work to try to understand what you
need to do and and how to get there
starting off with vendor tools and kind
of understanding what it is that they're
doing gets you a long way I'll tell you
right now probably their linker their
linker map is wrong but I've not seen
one that supports C++ correctly yet it
always needs some modification as well
as the startup code for initialization
of bits and pieces create create a
testbed that you can run on the target
that really test out the features of C++
that you expect to use extractions are
wonderful use good tools including
compiler Explorer if you are really that
concerned about it just use compiler
Explorer see what it is that you just
did measure measure measure measure
measure don't make decisions based upon
what you think is happening actually
measure it and then tests and and the
way you get to write tests is because
you make abstractions these abstraction
levels so that you can actually test you
know in a way that you you're not
refined only by the
the target hardware any questions yeah
Bryce Bryce's question is how much reuse
between projects do you end up having
and it depends upon all right different
things but how it kind of boils down to
is are you in the same cpu family that
you were in before or the impede family
MCU family and so that's going to cause
potentially great variations along the
way and the other is what kind of
peripherals are you using for this
project that you weren't using
previously those are going to cause
potential pain but there is kind of a
recipe once you get started and and you
know if you don't have a clue where to
start the best place to start is like go
grab linker script out of your the
compiler right now right and just take a
look at that that gives you an idea of
what you need to worry about at least
yeah Tony questions do I use variant for
polymorphism yeah so I actually do i do
use variant for polymorphism quite a bit
in fact it does it compiles down well
enough so I have I have a different
measure than than some people my measure
literally is does it fit on the device
and does it run fast enough and beyond
that I don't care right it's just not
worth my effort to put more into it yeah
so I do actually use variant quite a bit
I'm like nope not Michael John sorry
the question is is there an effort to
put linker scripts into github you so
when you get a compile or even this
bare-bones compiler it has linker
scripts already promised that the linker
script will probably not may not fit
your MCU memory map you need to muck
around with it I think you have a
comment there oh do I compile with
exception sorry let me get this coming
first yeah yeah so Tom's coming is that
it's kind of your start off with a basic
linker script and then there's stuff
you're going to do absolutely you're
gonna you're gonna start putting things
in to the linker script that you didn't
know that you were going to put in the
linker script the linker script some way
to give symbols associated with memory
for example because you're going to be
writing volatile a lot and wondering
whether or not the compiler is going to
get rid of that register that it thinks
doesn't exist so you know at some point
there are other tricks to get around
that and just creating in the linker
script is one way it's a simple now
that's not going away hopefully no
exceptions thank you exceptions John
right no we don't use exceptions and we
don't use exceptions for a variety of
reasons but but usually the largest
reason is the amount of bloat that comes
in with the exceptions we just turn them
on because that was actually slight wear
so the question was or the comment was
that there was no Artie TDI and which
one was the other one that was in it
yeah function sections so there are a
variety of other flags that you may want
to turn on that is one of them stack
unwind is the other one that you may
want to look at ya Yin's
okay so yeah the question is is the
overhead to achieve this worth it I
strongly believe the overhead to achieve
it it is well well worth it and the
reason the reason is because I get to
actually use the language to help find
errors that I know are going to exist
later on by having the type system
available to me it is going to find all
kinds of things that are very horrible
that may not be found otherwise
like like switching those to intz as a
perfect example right that that could
have really bad consequences that you
may not find until it gets to the field
because your testings weak or whatever
right but if I can if I can reduce the
number of bad things that might occur
and in an embedded system I you can
imagine that you know farmer Joe with
this thing that shaking trees doesn't
want an internet connection so I can
update his firmware when it doesn't work
it kind of has to just work when it goes
out and so anything I do to help prove
to myself that it does what it's
supposed to do you know I'll pay a lot
of time up front to make sure that
that's right well so my customers are
never upset it's the people in my
training that are upset so yeah so the
compiling stuff out I think is just it's
going to take time to help convince
people that they want to think at a
different level they don't want to use
their debugger to figure out what code
does they want a reason and understand
they want to let separate business logic
from the how things are going to get
done the how things are gonna get done
and I really want to know the details of
that and how it's going to work that
that's gonna be super important it's a
couple more
the scale of the project like how long
it depends on yeah I know I took his
upon the project this project is
probably nine months of effort or so I
think is what it will be and the tools
fighting with the tools probably was
about two weeks of effort of the C++
site Sharon's been fighting with the C
tools a lot but that's like the normal
what you expect to be fighting you're
going to do that with any embedded
project Chandler
Chandler's making the comment that that
our tool should actually be better at
helping us with debug mode that GCC is
good with the - Oh G and produces pretty
optimized code that's still debuggable
Microsoft's doing sounds like fairly
well at that - and and clang has some
ketchup that they're working on so that
would would also be helpful all right I
think we are well past time now all
right yeah I'm getting the Tony you're
well past time thank you for coming